I think fried foods is really nostalgic
obviously we fry a lot of food at tasty
there's for real methods to frying food
we're gonna go over our naked fry dredge
batter method and the fried chicken fry
it kind of like gets you in a party mood
we see a bunch of delicious freshly
fried food like freshly fried food or
bus frying is one of those things that
you really need to have everything
prepped before you get started so you
want a thermometer if for some reason
you have a grease fire
you want the tight-fitting lid tongs are
always great or a spider is even better
drying rack over some paper towel and
salt and sugar are both desiccants with
just mean that they help draw out
moisture which helps to ensure a nice
really crunchy crust so first of all
let's start with a naked fry the french
fries are one of those things you can
easily get pretty much any photo shop or
fast-food place but there's so much
better when you do them yourself
and all you need is some good russet
potatoes slice them into even slices
this is totally up to your preference
you can do wedges you could do very very
small shoestring potatoes Sarah's gonna
go for like pretty standard skin on
fries here and then right after they're
cut you want to get them into cold water
right away and that's going to help one
kind of clean off a lot of the starch in
potato and then also prevent them from
browning even though we washed our
potatoes first they're still just kind
of stuff that comes off when we get that
removal of that starch it just helps to
improve the crispy crunchiness
ize so it's a two-fold trick and for
these fries were actually double fry
them we're first gonna fry in a lower
heat that's gonna help us cook the fries
through it's pretty much safe to say
that anything that you're frying will
most likely be between 325 degrees
Fahrenheit and 375 degrees Fahrenheit so
you're just gonna fry them for a few
minutes they'll get a little bit of
color but they'll still look pretty pale
and you want to dump them out onto your
drying rack and immediately sprinkle
them with salt you can kind of judge
them a bit with your hands carefully as
well because they're gonna be hot as you
can see like they're still very tender
at this point and while those hang out
we're gonna crank up the heat on our
stove and get the temperature to 375
degrees and so that's gonna be a much
hotter oil and we're going to get really
really dark crunchy color and all of our
french fries and again when they come
out the second time you want to season
them as well
a nice big flaky kosher salt is always
really good as you can see now they're
very crunchy but they're soft and fluffy
on the inside and a really great rich
color looks so good so for a classic
dredge you need flour eggs and some sort
of crumb
whether it's bread crumbs panko you know
crushed cereal chips it could be a whole
bunch of things so what you want to do
is season your flour as well as your
bread crumbs and we're do that with salt
and pepper freshly ground of course and
that's pretty much it I mean it's pretty
easy what you want to do is make sure
that whatever you're frying is very dry
you're gonna fry some shrimp which are
super quick and so good
it's kind of just a matter of keeping
your hands clean which is the hardest
part about judging so you want to have
one hand for the wet and one hand for
the dry make sure it's really flowery
knock off any excess and then I use this
hand to cover it with pink oh you have
huge gaps in your pink oh you could dust
it with a little bit of flour after that
as well if you wanted to ensure that it
was completely coated
please take almost no time at all so
we're frying at 350 degrees as soon as
they're golden-brown they're pretty much
ready to come out when they come out you
can see how the tail is very pink it's
not the tell-tale sign to know what a
trip is go cut this shrimper the tail
get it ah
so young this is one of my favorite
fried foods it seems I don't know not
very exciting but trust me fried
zucchini done like this
it's like absolute heaven the way you
want to cut these is you want to have a
bit of skin on all of them so you cut
them on a little bit of a bias in two
rings and then cut those into small
pieces
you know don't lose sleep over it if
they're a little bit off like whatever
and what you need for this batter is
flour all-purpose is great olive oil
kind of put it in the corner you can
make a well first to start whisking the
oil into the flour if you do this all at
once it can get pretty clumpy so you
want to work on one side and slowly work
in the flour as you go and then you have
a perfectly smooth batter and what makes
this extra special is we're going to
fold in some whipped egg whites so this
is gonna give us a really cool aerated
batter that kind of like the same
consistency as a tempura but just a
little bit of a different method so you
want to be careful music going in you
kind of want to break them up because
they tend to clump together if not right
between 350 and 375 degrees is where you
want to beat for these
a little bit of batter will come off
that's totally normal don't worry and
you want to pick these out when they are
golden brown and crispy
as with all frying you're gonna put them
on to a drying rack or paper towel
afterwards and salt them to draw out the
moisture and make sure that they're
super crispy if you're gonna try
anything from this video you need to try
these all right on to the famous
buttermilk I'm just saying that this
recipe is famous but I don't think that
it it is it's going to be after this
video it's pretty easy what you want to
do the night before is get out some
buttermilk we're gonna season it with
freshly ground black pepper salt so
we've got cayenne dried thyme freaka and
garlic powder just mix it up to ensure
the buttermilk is totally seasoned and
then add your chicken
what buttermilk does it has a good
amount of acid in it and it helps to
tenderize the chicken if you don't have
buttermilk you could use milk with an
acid in there as well the common ratio
there is 1 cup of milk 2 1 tbsp of lemon
juice or white vinegar you want to cover
and put that in the fridge overnight if
you don't have overnight you could just
do it for a few hours but the longer you
leave it in there the longer the brine
can become penetrate and tenderize the
chicken so we'll take this out of the
brine and just let them kind of drain
out a bit
you don't them to be super wet when they
go into your flour and into the flour
I'm going to use the same mixture salt
and pepper dry thyme paprika garlic
powder and cayenne stir to make sure
it's evenly in the flour and then pretty
easy just dip your chicken in and ensure
that's evenly covered in the flour
because a little bit of the buttermilk
is still stuck to the chicken that's
gonna act just kind of our liquid that
the flour can stick to you do want to
knock off any excess because if there's
huge chunks of flour that aren't really
stuck to anything you'll end up with
kind of it's like weird
powdery fried chicken which we don't
want and the time will come off in your
oil so for this I actually keep the heat
of the oil up to 360 and the reason why
I do that is because the temperature of
the chicken is going to drastically drop
temperature of the oil we're trying to
cook our chicken around 325 degrees if
it goes much lower than that it would be
a little bit greasy er which was
definitely not we're going for it and
then once it's out of the fryer it's
gonna darken up just a little bit
so I would take it out it's got this
like a nice medium golden brown I would
say it'll go up a few degrees continue
cooking for a little bit it's a really
good idea to use an instant-read
thermometer and just make sure that all
the chickens cooked 165 degrees and
remember always salt things when they
come on the fryer that's gonna make a
great crust and also the last step of
seasoning before you're gonna eat oh so
good
fried chicken so when you're getting rid
of your oil first and foremost you need
it to cool down and you never put it
down the drain wait until the oil is
completely cooled you can pour the oil
into a jug but as you can see once all
the oil is back in it's actually pretty
clear and all of the bits are staying at
the bottom and that oil is actually good
to use for a few more times fried food
just has it all its crunchy its salty
its juicy once you master a few of these
techniques you can eat all the fried
food possible in moderation it's kind of
a fun thing that you can get your
friends to do with you as well you know
someone could be prepping the stuff
that's about to be fried someone can be
just hanging out drinking lawyer
actually frying it yeah I mean that's
fried food I'm just really hungry right
now and I want to go eat all this
[Music]